[Music]
and here we are good morning are we live
yeah we are live okay you know let's
watch that monitor there to up to
program if I'm just seeing the overlays
there's our second installment of good
morning bug Club live by the way we want
to see your Chet over there at leis
tv.com yeah that's right blaze tv.com
reading your live chat do leave a name
or an alias because we haven't quite
worked we wanted to get this up really
quickly for you we don't quite have the
we don't quite have the this creating
usernames working right can we just shut
that monitor or make it program because
I'm seeing everything that that Gibbon
is working on right now is overlays
which I very much appreciate oh yeah we
have a lot to get to we'll be talking
about Joe Biden's latest sexual assault
allegations the latest Ovid 19 wolf Lou
update sleaze as well as the stimulus
bill and um what are you have some
problems with with that and let us know
in the chat listen leave your name and
your what do you want us to talk about
most this is a more interactive show
it's more like a radio show what they
call the podcasts and the reason we're
doing this like I've said is we're not
first responders we're not doctors so we
can't create any we don't have a pillow
factory so we can't create yeah I mean
new masks for you but what we can do is
provide you with more content because we
know you're going a little bit
stir-crazy especially since the
quarantine has been extended so it is
hashtag mug Club quarantine if you want
to send in pictures of you with your mug
we might be reading some of those later
or tonight yeah and a lot of credit calm
/schedule is where you go to see the
full scheduled programming for the
entire month of April and use a promo
code quarantine ladder with Crider comm
slash mug Club you get $30 off that's
our biggest discount pretty locks at
apocalypse and please final thing if you
already member of my club please do
consider please just renew because
otherwise Vox has won this is a great
time to do that it's a great perfect
time to is a great time to renew okay so
we have a lot to get to by the way in
the news before we get to the stories
that we kind of want to talk about let's
do some fact-checking from the morning
yeah a morning roundup so really quickly
I think we have this clip from
Morning Joe where they made the claim
that everybody saw this come
early in January let's go to that now
we've heard Zeke Emanuel that nobody
could have seen this coming the fact is
everybody saw this coming
everybody saw this coming in early
January so I know it's I know you like
me now we've heard Zika met was that
what he said if we can get program up
there so I can see what they're saying
actually here's the thing the World
Health Organization said that there
wasn't any human human transmission as
of January 14th warnings are they didn't
even mention on the show until January
24th when they had an expert on there
who was by the way on there to still say
don't panic about the co vid whoa flu
here's another clip and how worried
should Americans be should they panic
good morning mica no Americans do not
need to panic
the Chinese are already panicking as
they should because this virus is
spreading all through the central parts
of China and it's a new virus it has
never been seen before so it's mechanism
of spreading is not quite known yet what
I would suggest however is that
Americans take this as a wake-up call
for seasonal flu we are not out of the
flu season Italy we've already had the
flu in the u.s. 140,000 of dog-whistle
name I don't know why your panic
everybody saw this coming I'm just going
back to that interview Morning Joe I
don't even know his I just call him
morning you pray right because it's
really his only value to society is this
Joe in the morning this is the kind of
Monday morning quarterbacking that
you're seeing from me it is remarkable
right right it as a left-right thing and
this is important for people to know
listen like I said I won't be shamed
into panicking we'll get into the
numbers were some people yesterday I
don't know if was Falchi or bricks not
Hans Brix screw that guy brick said the
death toll could be 100 220,000 in the
United States and I know some people are
panicked about that so we'll talk about
that a little bit more but they tried to
separate this did you notice into a
left-right issue right because before
that New York Times BuzzFeed is you see
Morning Joe they were all saying don't
panic it's not an emotion the seasonal
flu yeah they were wrong about that
okay we can all admit they were wrong
about that but then they try to
attribute the right meaning
conservatives saying hey listen we don't
know everything yet we do know it's not
as deadly as people are now trying to
tout this to be so we shouldn't shut
down our entire economy so we've
conflated the two everyone said it's
nothing then they said okay it's
something the right said we just don't
know how much of this something is and
is it worth the toll that is taking on
the economy therefore they try to make
it sound like we're deniers so using the
same techniques right now I notice
against people who think that this
pandemic needs to be handled seriously
but needs to be handled with a balanced
approach to both the livelihoods and the
lives of Americans and that's a problem
well there are these things going around
on Facebook and Twitter where it's like
Trump found out about the virus on X
date and then this is the number of
times he's like gone golfing since all
right
so it's like knowing about the virus is
not the same as knowing the extent right
and and but before anybody died and
obviously his response was you know his
response could have been good could have
been bad but the the issue is not when
he found out about it it's when he found
out about the severity which depends on
what's information he's getting right
which by the way this is something that
people need to think about how many
times have you had the sniffles or had a
sore throat and you thought yeah I think
it's just allergies I waited out and
gone into work it's not that serious
that's effectively where we were before
and I don't just mean Americans I don't
just mean the government the media and
certainly if you look at the time line
Donald Trump was doing more than the
media because it was around this time
where he put a travel ban on China it
was around this time where he was
actually consolidating so that we would
have a pandemic response team or task
force I don't know the exact terminology
don't hang me on it because if it's a
task force or pandemic response you know
what I mean to say promo code quarantine
$30 off let me know with your oh by the
way I forgot that we do not have Gerald
aid today right right you do not have
Hatter and Bill Richmond but in in third
chair today actually uh as an expert on
the the Chinese flu we do have a Bruce
Lee Bruce how are you sir well si
coronavirus can flow or it can crash
coronavirus if you put it into a cup it
becomes the cup if you put coronavirus
into a pillowcase it become
a pillowcase if you put coronavirus into
a rectum what's wrong with you okay oh I
see what's going on there Brittany I
think it's genius I you know what he was
all you were a horrible fighter
Bruce you were a terrible fighter
absolutely of no value at but you were a
brilliant and I appreciate your
expertise on kung-fu I'm more scared of
him now
than I would have been if he were yeah
yeah Bruce how how did you how did you
get to be here okay that's all just
gonna do is yeah
not really we now know that my lawyer
probably has a little bit more to
contribute than Bruce Lee
I mean he's an expert of sources not
immune from the corona I'm confused it
seems you that's one of the benefits of
the zombie apocalypse is they don't need
to worry about any one of several
benefits and isn't it bizarre with
zombies that immortality applies except
the brain stem will combine this idea of
sort of a pseudo spiritual element like
they're done dead they've come back it's
like well unless you hit that cervical
vertebra then there's nothing there's
nothing God can do that medulla some
weakness yeah so another morning roundup
do we have do we have the stinger from
that tree okay
morning roundup
[Music]
and the First Baptist bulletin is in the
church foyer a big advantage that you
guys all Bible studies are cancelled oh
but we will have unless it's a Bible
study of ten or less people right
exactly and we're gonna have by the way
even Brendan on the show because he has
to wear a lot of protective gear because
we're worried that he might be infected
and we'll have Brautigan of course
senior news correspondent on later with
the morning after a roundup of all the
news from the week and of course traffic
updates because we want to keep you
abreast yourself here's something that's
pretty telling you know Donald Trump
right his actually you know what let's
go to CNN really quickly before I trash
them I want to hear if they got
themselves a microphone Florida Governor
under pressure to issue statewide
shutdown now this may seem trivial right
may seem like it doesn't matter and we
will get to the projected death rates
that they talked about last night but
this this does matter because right now
they are they have a Chiron going on
that Florida might be pressured to issue
a statewide shutdown yeah but there is
nothing in the news that the FDA
approved new drugs and therapeutics to
combat coronavirus yeah there was
nothing on CNN as a running headline
telling that we have the ability to
sanitize up to four hundred thousand
masks and the my pillow guy was speaking
at a briefing because 75,000 masks will
be coming out of his factory per day so
this would be totally fine in a 24-hour
news cycle yeah if it were the most
important news but it's not well in CNN
knows that it is part of the pressure
right so like putting the chyron up is
adding pressure to it right so they're
there cooking at all it's it's all
basically using the news media as a way
of steering politics absolutely cutting
down and saying we're not watching I
want to certainly I don't want to get
them talking about so here's another
fast fact by the way Donald Trump's
approval ratings have been going up I'm
doing so here's so stock market this
doing this actually the stock market
doesn't at long-term it still does this
so if you sold all your stock if you
sold everything in your 401k you screwed
up right this is not the time to cash
out exactly I don't care how much Kramer
you watch is it Jim Kramer I don't
remember
he's the financial guy is the equivalent
to Gallagher
bonk yeah and like Gallagher always
funny always funny
I want to take my financial advice from
that guy
CNN of course because the approval
ratings are going up and this should
this should be pretty telling I think
the folks out there because remember
Rachel Maddow came out yeah not long ago
and said we need to stop airing the
prompt the prompt the Trump press please
right yeah because this is propaganda we
need to stop airing it and then I think
it was HuffPo these other websites said
we need to stop doing this because his
approval rating was going up now again
it's not sort of like new media when
we're not being gamed by the algorithms
which is why we need to hit the
notification bell we do better than a
lot of the shows that are on network
television right Donald Trump when he
doesn't have to go through the
intermediaries we just have to go
through these gatekeepers there you go
you can hear the notification they'll
hit all notifications if you're
subscribed of course iTunes Android all
of that router bit subscribe we're
putting up more content than they're up
there than ever if he doesn't have to go
through them in other words he does
enough to go through Maddow right people
hear what he has to say directly right
his imperial ratings go up here's the
thing you may not like what Donald Trump
has to say but that's about as pure of a
litmus test as you get yeah people
watching him directly saying all right I
like what you say right now you may want
a fact check what he's saying and that's
your job as journalists it's your job to
fact check it correctly by the way no
not fact check Donald Trump because he
says we have some side liquids to
sanitize amass and people go there's no
spray that'll sanitize him it wasn't on
an x-ray he was talking about a machine
by the way I just found out that our
dryer they don't also have this you can
let me know in the chat our dryer your
office dryer has a sanitized steam cycle
oh that's nice and then it also has just
throw the masks in there well it hasn't
anti microbial cycle - and I'm not
entirely sure that I understand the
difference but I do wonder if people
mocked Donald Trump mercilessly for
saying hey we should be able to sanitize
these masks like is it outside of the
realm of possibility if whirlpool
figured it out yeah if doctor why are
they trained why are they expecting the
president to know about these chemicals
that will sanitize thinks he's just
saying hey I think we might have some
chemicals that could sanitize these mats
low energies alright and absolutely
worked yeah and then the my pillow guy
said that God left public schools so you
know yes the CNN may have been
uncomfortable enough to pull the
broadcast but Fox and MSNBC both ran
right so there and they're pretending to
be nonpartisan they're pretending to be
yes virus but MSNBC who had admittedly
biased fox who is admittedly biased and
now that's the point now it's migrated
to CNN so CNN is taking cues from
salon.com in Rachel Maddow I want to
make that really clear and then they'll
go with this logo that says just the
facts right that's the thing we've seen
I don't have a problem with Rachel
Maddow I don't people go hey why don't
you focus on them so much visually maybe
if we want to rebut them that's fine and
wonder about an argument but I don't
have a problem with media buys from
MSNBC from places like the Young Turks
from people who are opinion journalists
I don't I have a problem with trying to
claim that you were unbiased and lying
to people about it
so last night scene and refused to air
president Trump's press conference which
is interesting because then they tried
to pull some information from the press
conference that they now think obviously
makes a situation look very dire so they
want to tell people that everything is
terrible but they don't want to tell you
that hey you know what private industry
stepped up and we're going to have in
abundance of masks and tests that's very
quickly despite the FDA and CDC so um
matter of fact CNN they didn't air
here's what's most telling they didn't
air the briefer last night instead they
decided that their news time would be
best suited to covering this I don't
know why you take your shot at that I
mean you know just because you don't
cook I mean mom shares her secrets about
how to make sauce very few people I mean
you shouldn't break ties yourself that
you're not one of the people that mom
saw as worthy to run about mom spaghetti
I'm sure she would have is just that you
spent so much more time in the kitchen
Chris mom's little helper in the kitchen
I really respect that and always under
force in the kitchen when you think of
it I don't I'm gonna see if I see some
common ground
brothers Cuomo we need to offend you
taken taken but you helped mom in the
kitchen was a beautiful thing I had to
do keep in mind
exact moment they were talking about
precautionary measures to be taken
during this pandemic where are you where
are you I'm gonna man wants to know
where you were
mom I know where you are where are you
physically I'm just shocked Thurs
members of the CDC our commander in
chief were providing valuable
information to the American public but
they are so dead set on making sure that
Donald Trump can't speak to you directly
that they decided to air that's too old
monitor grab out there mom Elmo's a
nervous mom spaghetti shut up oh I hope
you both choke on your spicy meat-a-ball
and see I figure if I do it without
effort it's not racist if I said spicy
meat-a-ball you know maybe media manager
can write but if I just say spicy more
like a Jeff Goldblum
that's a spicy meatball but you would
never yeah you would never there it is
yeah you never do an actual like
cartoonish caricature I would never not
on this show what do you think about
that Bruce do you think that was
responsible for the new cycle well see
if you put an [ __ ] on CNN CNN becomes
the [ __ ] [ __ ] can fart or [ __ ]
can talk and CNN [ __ ] get national
platform it doesn't make any sense
you know what these tidbits are not
valuable no I think he's insightful okay
see that was a little ventriloquism I
don't need a special for it Jeff Dunham
we get it you got a puppet with the
racist voice what else you got puppets
so here's something else let me know put
your name in there for the chat will be
live chatting folks over there in the
blaze
dr. Burks right the US officials
initially responded to the coronavirus
the way they did because they thought it
was going to be more like they said more
like a SARS type epidemic not a global
pandemic which by the way anyone know
where SARS came from
there's a trend here named Bruce sorry
okay yeah you you started he's repentant
he is repent yeah look he is not humble
man even as a drug addict / fraud
fighter yes not beyond redemption no
he's a legend as well and they said that
they were missing so again I want to be
we want to be careful here I want to
make sure the people understand we're
not trying to downplay the pandemic I
want you to remember that the media
who's blaming President Trump for it for
some reason just like Hurricane Katrina
was a was george w bush's force because
he caught you know hurricane katrina
started talking about it george w bush
bought a plasma ball at Spencer's whoa
and then flood it all so they decided to
build a town was it five hundred feet
below sea level I'm not sympathetic but
I also don't fully understand why we're
rebuilding at a place that has to have
that happen again
like let's just you know find the
nearest it doesn't have to be a mountain
like a mound like I would just say let's
make New Orleans like a pitcher's mound
just me you know and just build house it
was a humanity Habitat for Humanity how
president go in there and put it on a
hill yeah Jimmy Carter come on over just
put it on a hill so we don't have to
blame it on the next president so again
this is right now dr. Burke's talking
about how they were missing a
significant amount of data and they
believe this is going to be more SARS
like here you go could we have known
something different you know I think all
of us I mean I was overseas when this
happened in Africa and I think when you
looked at the China data originally and
you said oh well there's 80 million
people are 20 million people in Wuhan
and 80 million people and who Bay what
and they come up with a number of 50,000
I don't know lime no ice then you do
this kind of global pandemic it's my
beverage of choice
oh okay so a couple things are important
I've talked about this there's a finite
amount of resources with government and
this is something that the left gets
perfectly wrong so before I move on with
more statistics that whole but I can try
to you a little bit of context here and
a lot of the times
when people say I'll I just take issues
as they come on an individual issue by
interest you should look at every issue
critically but you should start off with
a worldview there's nothing wrong with
an ism provided that it is correct you
know everyone has one you need to be
honest about it and a worldview will
help determine at least how you sift
through information that is superfluous
and you don't have time for the left has
an ism that is perfectly wrong let's
look at yes left-right third party man
this isn't for you right now so the
right we understand that free enterprise
is not there it's not a finite sum not a
finite amount a lot of the left they say
well I want a piece in my pot not
infinite I want some of my I want some
of that cheddar
no no it's that's not finite it is
actually you can build more pies yeah
yeah let me go over this you can build
more pies in the free enterprise in
other words how do you build more pies
well you have a rotary phone then you
have a touchpad then you have a cell
phone they have a cordless phone then
you have an iPhone so when people say
they'll tell the telecommunications
industry is really hurting guess what
and you say I want a piece of my pie
your pie now the iPhone is created now
that creates work for whole new app
developers games right all the kinds of
software that have made Everett that
have improved everybody's lots you can
go and bake more pies in a free
enterprise system job by contrast the
government cannot bake more pies there
is a finite amount of money because you
sooner or later and sooner rather than
later run out of revenue that you can
generate by taxing people and that's
something called the Laffer curve a lot
of people think we can just tax the
wealthy 100% they leave so it's even
lower of a threshold than that but let's
say that's the ultimate threshold you
can tax people at 100% the government
can generate no more revenue than that
effectively not including dividends or
some other investments right we
understand that still compared to the
private sector the Left sees it
differently they see private industry as
a piece of the pie that's why Bernie
Sanders or Cortes need to redistribute
it and then they look at government and
see it as an infinite sum that we should
be paying people indefinitely providing
free health care free internet free take
your pick and I'm not exaggerating in
Germany internet was declared a
fundamental human right which is
dangerous because it
the government can take away a right
once they declare it to be a right under
their purview so this is remote least in
those countries they don't have a
constitution so the right understands
private enterprise
you can bake more pies government very
limited in what they can generate you
left
seized private industry as evil villains
who need to have their wealth
redistributed and the government this
all-knowing altruistic entity that can
generate profit from scratch they
couldn't be more incorrect and that's
how you are looking at two sides viewing
this pandemic so how you view the world
matters before you look at it on an
individual issue by issue basis you need
to determine how you understand the free
market and the government's capability
to extend these bailouts indefinitely
and the longer the government props up
these older industries the slower that
growth will be right - the slower that
those new pie's will end up being baked
right and then some of them end up being
cobblers notes most said I don't know
the difference between a pie the cobbler
I don't miss you maker I know what an
apple crisp is it's what has an OD crust
yeah but I hear southerners always lay
eggs the best peach cobbler first off if
you like peach anything you're weird
it's disgusting no Sh
no fruit should run the risk of
folliculitis I do not like peaches I
think it's the shape a pioneer cobbler
yeah I think I think it's the shape is a
cobbler hi there's a cobbler like baked
with the top on it top in a bottom I'm
seeing like it oh we have the overlay
here we have the fact what's the
dimension of a cobbler in a pie do we
know well Google has told us young
Google it says one way to differentiate
between PI and cobbler is through the
crust
Oh pies are encased in pastry either
just on the bottom or on both top and
bottom
cobblers on the other hand are simply
topped with some sort of baked pastry or
dough that sounds very much like a
technicality I've never seen a pie in my
life without a crust on top I've never
gone on pie
forget about this we've gone too far
we've gone too far and we're getting
loose what's your opinion on on the pine
cobbler well see if you put a pie into a
crust it becomes a crust if you put a
cobbler under the pastry it becomes the
pastry table can flow or it can crash in
cake is just a vehicle for frosting well
okay I understand you're a pie guy yeah
he's a pie guy what about is more of a
dumpling guy here's another thing that's
pretty important finite resources this
is why I wanted to bring that up so you
understand there are finite resources
with the government that they cannot
necessarily bake more pies January 29th
what was Donald Trump doing he was
forming the coronavirus task force
January 29th what were the Democrats
doing around that time shift was
delivering On February 3rd closing
impeachment arguments so keep this in
mind I want when we now talk about how
we should have known this was coming and
the government should have been more on
alert and done their job I don't have
the ability to bring up every single
show and watch it in fast time for you
throughout January 29th to February 3rd
but I'm willing to bet if you remember
going to your memory bank you remember
all of the headlines about Adam Schiff
swatch job Donald Trump yeah
oh she destroyed Graham anything about
the corona virus being a global pandemic
that Donald Trump wasn't prepared for no
we were still on impeachment and if you
are President of the United States or if
you remember really any of the
significant branches of government you
can't be both preparing for a global
pandemic that nobody at that point had
truly identified as a pandemic and
simultaneously dealing with one of the
biggest impeachment shams in modern it
throughout all of American history yeah
there are only so many resources to go
around all of your headlines CNN we're
about impeachment Adam Schiff and now
you want to go back no why would it why
wouldn't the American public prepare
because you basically were a glorified
you're a glorified sub Network for
c-span running shift yeah like it was a
morphine drip and now of course a number
has come out so people are afraid Brooke
said the number could be a hundred
thousand to two hundred twenty thousand
deaths
that'd be terrible if it was true I
don't buy it now let me tell you this is
just totally opinion I think it's
important to note that first off all of
their projections have been wrong okay
every single projection that may have
been wrong in the UK was made 500
thousand others saying 20 thousand or
less we talked about that yesterday in
the United States they said 2.5 million
then they're saying a hundred to two
hundred something thousand also
important to note is we don't really
have the most accurate way of accounting
for deaths that are solely coronavirus
related this is something people don't
fully understand that in any influenza
season about seven to fourteen percent
of viruses that go around are some form
of corona virus not this new form of nut
that's why it's novel coronavirus but if
you bring out Clorox or you bring out
some you know industrial cleaner you'll
see that it says it kills corona virus
so Carter virus has been around for a
while even including what we have now if
you were to add them all under global
influenza deaths
it wouldn't be significant enough at
this point to be a blip and something
that's really important in New York City
is what we're talking about okay New
York City is saying if the country goes
the way of New York City we could have a
hundred thousand a two hundred twenty
thousand deaths and I'm not saying that
that cannot happen but I do think we
need some context here I have a number
of the 790 deaths in the city of course
these numbers are apt to change 777 of
the patients 98% had underlying
conditions in Italy over 99% of
coronavirus beta patients had other
health problems the average age was 79
years old well so I want to be clear
about that that still looks if you look
at a hundred thousand that looks like a
lot obviously it is a lot they also
talked about the guy who created this
Imperial study up Ferguson said well
really if you look at these deaths
two-thirds of them are actually from
people who would have died within the
next several months to a year anyway
meaning not just existing conditions but
stage 4 lung cancer emphysema right
serious respiratory illnesses and this
accelerated it not saying that we
shouldn't help them unlike Italy who
says you're on your own
that being said that does change how we
deal with this as a society when you
understand that only 1% in Italy were
younger than the age of 70 and healthy
and in New York 2% were young and
healthy the death rate is
very very different and we are still
treating everybody out there as though
they are part of this 98% demographic of
people over the age of 79 with serious
pre-existing conditions so even if you
look at that hundred thousand number
you're looking at possibly ninety to
ninety eight thousand people who were
going to pass away within the next
couple of months to a year anyway and it
was accelerated by coronavirus now
what's important about that is I'm not
saying this is insignificant but those
same people who are going to die anyway
who maybe have cancer who maybe the
emphysema would also die if they got
some sort of serious pneumonia or flu
that would accelerate it as well so take
that number a hundred thousand and based
on all the data that we have two
thousand would be people who are young
and or healthy yeah so it is a very
different picture if somebody only has a
corona virus and dies or if it's just
the final straw just a straw the bright
camel's back it and you can't deal with
those things and but it's not that's not
how it's being reported at all no
nobody's talking about it's not how it's
being reported and here's the reason it
bothers me so much is let's follow the
sequence of events okay Rachel Maddow
says don't air the Trump press briefing
so does salon so does slate so does
HuffPo so MSNBC doesn't do it then CNN
says we're not going to run the press
briefings so they don't run the press
briefings in those press briefings
Donald Trump says hey the FDA just
approved a drug these therapeutics that
have had a really high rate of efficacy
we are creating hundreds of thousands of
masks and able to sanitize hundreds of
thousands more this is this is the
silver lining right now look at all
these Americans who are coming together
without having to be coerced by the way
what's what's happening we're gonna clip
without having to be coerced by the way
that's not broadcast but then they pull
a snippet from the press briefing that
they didn't run saying a hundred
thousand at two hundred twenty thousand
Americans are going to die again without
context at ninety eight percent of the
ones in New York City were with
pre-existing conditions that timeline
and you tell me that the media has your
best interest at heart
and this isn't just about doesn't mean
that the information is not accurate
okay I want to be clear about this yeah
okay we had I want to make sure the
numbers right seven hundred ninety
deaths at the time of when we were doing
this fact-checking the morning seven
hundred ninety deaths in the city of New
York City in New York City I know that
was redundant
okay that's true that is true but
context does matter when 98% of them
involved old people or people with
pre-existing conditions that is also
true so when you choose to only pick a
fact that is a total number without
context and you choose to not broadcast
the fact that we have new therapeutics
that we have more masks that we've made
advancements with antibodies that tells
me that you are not looking to provide
just the facts yeah yeah it's an
illustration of what we've talked about
for a long time that that the news media
doesn't necessarily care about reporting
the facts it cares about
rustling up this narrative to make sure
that they can use it for their own
political well-being or the write their
own ideological concerns yeah it's
serious business data like that shows us
like what you said we know who the the
people that are at risk are right people
that are older and have pre consisting
illnesses yeah so why don't we take them
and we focus on this idea that was my
idea I pointed at you and I said you
said well you know what the reason that
you're willing to say it now is because
I told you this might be a career ender
all right here I said several weeks ago
I said no one else is saying this but
okay first off this part isn't about I
freaking hate old people so they smell
like old library books no I said why are
we talking about essential businesses
that can stay open right why aren't we
talking about non-essential businesses
that could adapt or modify their
workflow and why are we telling everyone
to quarantine instead of simply
quarantine old people and people at risk
and another thing people don't
necessarily know who to trust when they
came out the CDC and said you shouldn't
be wearing masks right hold on a second
you also praised South Korea its mask
city you can't find them without a mask
you could not pick a mugger a pickpocket
er I don't know they call them in South
Korea out of a police lineup because
they're all the same height same hair
same eye color and then a mask really
the only way I can tell the difference
is by the lip by the cleft and I can't
say that there's no but they all mugged
me
they all made me officer they cuffed on
me and I gave them my wife's purse so
they all wear masks now the CDC I think
you can bring this up now they're saying
they're considering an order of putting
on masks now yes it is not a 100%
effective
neither than 95 respirator and then you
go lower than that a surgical mask no
it's not you know what else people were
saying well don't try and make masks at
home right with with t-shirts or with
whatever fabrics you have there's and
that's not going to work they look I
looked online to say well no no no maybe
there is a way to make a mask it turns
out the most effective masks and by the
way you can go to origins of Maine they
have masks and here we'll bring Brennan
in a little bit he has to wear a mask
all day a lot of companies making great
masks but I searched how to make an
at-home mask that might at the very
least be passable provide some benefit
and the study came back saying that
actually a t-shirt Multi multi blend
like poly cotton blend I guess helps and
it was no effective than a plain cotton
t-shirt or an antimicrobial pillow were
about 70 something percent effective at
filtration and almost entirely effective
at blocking droplets so learning how to
do the ninja but guess what I found
there the CDC conducted these studies
and now sooner no don't wear a mask
because at the time it wasn't about
whether they work it was about shortages
for health care workers and by the way
if masks don't work at all
why do health care workers need them so
much yeah I understand they need them
more we should get them the masks first
because they're dealing in close
proximity with people who have the
corona virus but that's what we're now
talking about people who are carriers
who don't know that they're carriers
let's put everyone in mass yeah they
don't think that you can handle that
information so they have to lie to you
and say that they don't work
yeah they don't think that you can
actually discern that okay well I
shouldn't buy it but maybe somebody else
should I think every single citizen of
the United States who's walking out
there should look like they've just left
Arkham Asylum or our scorpion from
Mortal Kombat they should all be wearing
masks there's no reason not to Hey look
there's a mask on scene and let's see
what they're doing in fact check it real
quick
considering the fact that they too could
be putting themselves in harm's way she
broadcasting from a war zone
where's Geraldo Rivera this is another
thing some hospitals are seeing surges
yeah what they don't tell you is that
some hospitals are seeing surges because
everyone wants to be tested for
coronavirus right now the surge does not
mean that everyone is an intensive-care
some people are and that's why it's
really important that you don't go to
the emergency room if you have some mild
symptoms there's not much they can do
for you right now don't overload the
system all right I think we actually
have a traffic report right Thomas
Finnegan let's do this we know that many
of you are stuck at home but we still
want to assist you make your day as
convenient passable as possible it's
time to go to the traffic report with
Thomas Finnegan
[Music]
all right mr. Finnegan are you there sir
I am Here I am doing well mr. Finnegan
what do we have this morning what should
people look out for on their morning
commute well this morning there's some
light congestion in the kitchen as you
make your approach to the coffee pots as
we ought to look out for that and
someone left me a seat on last night so
be sure to bundle up if you're coming in
from the bedroom
I appreciate that Thomas Finnegan keep
us abreast if anything develops this has
been morning traffic report with Thomas
Finnegan
[Music]
all right and let us know if there's
anyone in chat send your send your chats
to us with a screen name so that we can
actually hear from you and I can read it
on here do we have anything we do no one
was watching oh they are they are so we
have one from Andrew he says thanks for
keeping us entertained renewed my
subscription at the beginning of March I
think we do have others here yeah let's
see Nathan says talk about the
ridiculous release of rapists in
Rochester New York I haven't heard about
that's not heard people proposing yeah I
live here and it's disgusting mayor
lovely Warren and the Democratic
leadership here are ruining the area I
don't know that that's happened yeah
yeah I know it was disposed yeah Nathan
so I don't I don't want to speak out of
turn here and I think that I can hedge
my words and safely say that um
releasing rapists during a pandemic
seems like a bad idea
yeah I mean talk about rape color I
wouldn't co I wouldn't put my John
Hancock on that bill because someone
else is putting the John Hancock through
your window I don't want yeah
rapists release I don't understand this
at all and this can be ism if you
believe that it's a prison industrial
complex and that prison should only be
about rehabilitation and not punishment
you know what I believe it split the
difference okay I think that prison
should be as uncomfortable as legally
possible and hopefully we can
rehabilitate all of these people I don't
want it to be like Sweden where you
commit some kind of a serious violent
crime and you effectively get put in an
Ikea display case okay I don't want that
I don't want you going to prison where
you have more than most people in
Manhattan their junior suite apartment I
think we need to balance punishing
people as a deterrent and rehabilitating
people then again that's my worldview as
a conservative so it does dictate that
releasing serial rapists into the small
town of Rochester in New York sounds
like it could come with some
complications I don't know I'm not a
rape doctor we do have another chat here
from quirky blue nine okay says had this
remark show up in my Facebook feed and
I'd love to know how you would respond
they were remarking on Trump's comment
that the u.s. wasn't built to shut down
basically they were calling capitalism
bad because it can't shut down even in a
crisis to take care of people uh that's
bad people saying I guess all of a
sudden can't stop won't stop became a
demotivation like the fact that the
train keeps on choo choo choo I think I
can I think I can what would these
people prefer I think I [ __ ] up what
do they want it today I don't this is
this is markable to me shouldn't we all
be rooting for the country right now to
come back shouldn't we all be in other
words if you have a negative story omits
a pandemic and you have a success story
like private entry stepping up and
creating masks or now that we have the
ability to create testing kits first it
went down to five minutes then I went
down to two minutes what seized private
laboratories was an abbot and I don't
know the other laboratory we talked
about him yesterday and they don't have
to stick an iron rod in the back of your
skull like it's some sort of a lesson
being learned from Kevin Spacey and
seven that's a good thing that's a
wonderful thing if we have to pick
between that and well you know what more
people in New York aren't having access
to ventilators listen that's terrible
but we should also really make sure that
we highlight the hope yeah when it goes
back to the left calling all of that
false hope
right so if Trump is not saying 100%
negative things if he's including things
like hey there's actually some promise
here and the private industry in private
industry then that is false hope yeah
that's actually hope it's actually a way
out of this whole thing just because it
was saying if he was saying negative
things that you say he's fear-mongering
yeah well he's false hope would be there
is no coronavirus okay
fake news we're also false hope is not
Americans will come together and fight
this enemy and show our strength and
resolve and industries have stepped up
without the need of the defense
production Act without that they've
stepped up and they're making hundreds
of thousands of masks and making the
capabilities to sanitize hundreds of
thousands more that's not false hope you
guys were asking for masks now you're
getting masks and they're not recyclable
yeah when did that go out the window is
something relevant aoc
recyclable masks if there's ever
anything that should make you borderline
climax in your government chair mitts
the hearing it should be masks that can
now be sanitized and recycled 20 times
that were single-use it's a lot more
complicated to make than a straw yeah
so the message is clear you're not
allowed to be happy right correct you
are not not only happy you're not
allowed to broadcast we want to this is
really what it comes down to they want
to shut down the briefings because the
breathing the briefings include keep in
mind the death figures that you're
hearing about now that came from
president Trump's briefing folks he
brought the doctor out so people give
him crap why are you bring up to my
pillow guy you know why cuz of my pillow
guy retooled seventy five percent his
factory said he'll be able to do fifty
thousand masks today that's an American
success story that's good and then he
brings someone out to say hey the death
rate could be a hundred to two hundred
thousand people the information that you
were getting today in the news was from
Donald Trump's briefing you know he's
not only going out and spouting good
news he's going out and telling the
truth yeah and the reason they don't
want to broadcast it is because they
want to pull the bad news without the
context of the good news yeah and that
is what bothers me it's the lies by
omission that are so toxic also toxic
the Cuomo brothers I would just I mean
nipple rings like rings oh can you bring
that up Cuomo has a nipple ring yeah I
think they're bars which yeah it's the
mayor the governor yeah yeah I would
have thought it was Chris I know he
seems like the nipple ring kind of guy
knows the governor's wrinkle was the
term of the one in the tip and the tip
of what's right something Prince I'm not
I'm not one to say I don't really I just
call it I call it the Ascot the Joe
exotic had one he's right he had one he
used to put a little lock on it can we
see guys I had no idea that Cuomo had
nipple oh yes you gotta bring that up
but he does have coronavirus oh so this
is we're including the good news with
the bad
good news being nipple rings there's no
positive in this press briefer Cuomo has
coronavirus and nipple rings yeah
it's promises this is the worst thing
that's ever happened to this show all
right let me know when you have it yeah
and you can bring it up so let's move on
to the next point here that I think is
pretty important I think we already told
people at the notification we do have a
nipple ring let me see a nipple ring
sure
there we go here it is we can we can
scroll down a little bit as you go right
there
that may not be nipple rings may have a
straight line hair yeah and it has those
little like goose bumps around whatever
yeah whatever the case is the the
message is clear Governor Cuomo has
weird nipples well I really hope that he
doesn't hang around with his brother
because that would be a pre-existing
condition that would put him at risk I
mean because I would imagine the corona
virus can enter through the nipple way
there's a lot of capillary circulation
ah the next thing that I want to get to
here's I want to talk about the stimulus
bill because I think this matters I
think a lot of people skimmed over it
and this is a the biggest spending bill
in American history are done so I think
it deserves a little bit of attention
and there are some pros there are some
cons and I think that the media has been
pretty irresponsible and not covering
all the above let's go to clip C please
what did the Senate majority fight for
one of the largest corporate bailouts
with as few strings as possible in
American history
shameful the greed of that fight is
wrong okay so a couple of fast facts
here every single Senate Democrat
including the person a OSE endorsed for
president Bernie Sanders signed on they
voted for the DA they voted for the bill
so let's be clear about that
it's going to cost a whole lot I think
there's something that's lost in this
when we're talking about the stimulus
bill there are some good things here
okay
I think it's small businesses they're
gonna have forgivable loans for up to
ten million dollars the qualifications
we don't exactly understand what they
are right now let me know if you're
chatting right there if you're a small
business owner how you've been affected
economically from this and all we can
really do for you guys is try to offer
this as close to cost as possible and
your promoter promo code quarantine and
you get $30 off but I think that this
stimulus bill unfortunately and I know I
might lose some of the the Trump
cultists here I think I've been pretty
fair
is not targeted enough I know that
you're more of a libertarian so am i
wait but I think it correct me if I'm
wrong I believe that it is appropriate
for the government to provide some kind
of restitution for businesses that they
effectively have shut down yeah well so
the Fed has basically set itself up as
the lender of last resort right and we
can't act like they can't not be the
lender of last resort if they've already
set themselves up that way right I don't
think the Fed should exist but this is
not the time to like the Fed may very
well end after this but it's it's yeah
we're basic this is the solution and the
the pattern of solutions that have been
set up since Wilson right but I do think
at this point for example the owner of
the restaurant down the block when the
government steps up and says nobody go
to restaurants shut down your doors
effectively it's like a mobster coming
in and knocking tables over right saying
no more restaurant I do think that it is
far more appropriate and the argument
can be made and I would agree with that
argument that is the government's job to
try and alleviate what ails that
business because it was brought on by
government right yeah well the sort of
bailout model is the model that we've
been using again for a hundred years so
it's right or wrong this is the way
things are basically well necessarily
it's different for example so this is
not some that was created by years of
that policy so if you look at the crash
right of 2008 and you look at Fannie Mae
Freddie Mac and you look at or so you
have Fannie Mae Freddie Mac dodd-frank
dodd-frank is banking Fannie Mae Freddie
Mac I believe is the housings and Barney
Frank was running a brothel in the
basement that's the real main takeaway
but that was created why and all I don't
understand this too they just go oh oh
subprime loan and predatory lenders this
is something that's really silly and I'm
gonna come back around to the current
stimulus bill predatory lending is such
a silly term to me yeah yeah cuz that
assumes that a bank is gonna hey wait
you know hey all right
mr. chase I got a business model for you
all right I'm listening Johnson ah you
know how we lend money to people and you
know we make sure like we charge
interest in the money when they know
when they pay it back with interest
that's all we make money yeah and we
have a very lengthy pre-screening
process to make sure that the right
candidates who can pay these loans back
because that's how they make money the
interesting thing you know okay I have a
picture this we lend the money
and lower interest than normal to people
we're never gonna pay that they have no
chance of paying it back Johnson I like
it this is why you're vice president
communications relations think about
that predatory lending it doesn't make
any sense unless the loans were not only
guaranteed and underwritten by the
government but we're thrust upon the
bank's why why because of woke nests
because of ensuring uncle outcomes it
was you need to lend these subprime
loans to people who cannot afford these
homes in other words the standard was I
think 20 to 30 percent down yeah I don't
know what the interest rate was right
before the crash they said we're gonna
we're gonna lower it to sometimes almost
nothing down 5% 8% 10% down and less
interest to make sure that not only
minorities they tried to they tried to
couch it as though this was was created
for minorities but it wasn't it was
created for people who had not purchased
homes before and had no business living
in these homes at these prices the
government created that bubble forced
banks to take part then of course there
was money on the table so banks got
greedy they took advantage of it they
packaged these all up together to try
and minimize risk that didn't work and
then we ended up with the housing crash
and then the government steps in to bail
out the banks that is wrong on so many
levels and that happened over the course
of years you could argue really decades
this happened over the course of a month
and the government stepped in and said
hey owner of the Dunkin Donuts franchise
over there on Willow Creek way you're
gonna shut down because we need to
prevent infection I think the banks
right Goldman Sachs Bear Stearns all of
those mm they shouldn't have been bailed
out I don't think it anyone is too big
to fail mm-hmm
I think that's different from these
companies here who have been shut down
within the span of a month not because
of decades of bad policy and those
business owners these small business
owners did not abuse the system to
create any ill-gotten gain the banks did
right yeah and so I think that's
important to delineate and that's the
problem I have with this stimulus bill
look there's a lot that's going to small
businesses that's great but Airlines
they're going to be receiving fifty
eight billion dollars right twenty-nine
billion and grants 29 billions in loans
and guarantees as well as some reprieve
from taxes this is unreal to me because
the airlines were going to be there a
couple
from now with their hand out anyway they
always are and I understand also it's
really hard to make money in the airline
industry why because of energy costs
because of all the new regulations that
they create and yeah you do have some
people at the airlines are greedy the
fact that only spirit well actually no
spirit charges you more for it carry-on
right it's the it's the Greyhound bus /
WNBA of the sky don't fly spirit unless
someone's dead okay yes like I always
tell people don't call me after 10:30
unless someone is dead do not show up on
the tarmac in an airplane Martha spirit
unless you are in a corona hotbed and
it's escape from New York and you have
an eyepatch I don't want to see that
logo anywhere near me because it's
probably a bunch of rapists who've been
left out from Rochester yeah so the
airlines are the 90 year old who gets
coronavirus great analogy audio way why
thank you I don't think that the airline
should get any bailouts sure yeah I
don't think I should at all I thought
emotive should and here's the thing that
people don't think about too they go oh
if we don't have Airlines people won't
be able to travel that's not true
because guess what there will be an
airline who won't need a bailout
probably in a company like Southwest or
JetBlue hey maybe vert remember everyone
loved flying virgin when virgin went
away even though I know Richard Branson
is a kind of a weird guy you know he
does the Iowa hot air balloon but still
Virgin Airlines everyone talked about
how it was like a party in the sky had a
weird LED lighting it came with a
complimentary snack people love virgin
this is Branson Richard Branson yeah
yeah he has more money than almost
anybody I mean Jeff Bezos sees his
fortune and thinks it's cute but sure
this guy has so much money in virgin
airlines couldn't compete why because
you cannot compete against American
against Delta against United I don't
know they probably all merged at some
point now because my points don't really
make sense anymore I want to get a free
ticket free cocktail Delta can I get a
free cocktail the point is even Richard
Branson couldn't compete against the
airlines with a never fly federal
funding yeah how many big new banks come
out lately not a whole with goldman
sachs when every time they speed up the
government steps in and bails them out
yeah this prohibits new companies from
stepping in and creating competition and
if we didn't give anyone
Airlines right now we might see a virgin
step-up we might see Southwest create
more flights we may see Jeff blue Jeff
Luc Jeff will actually - he's a great
pilot but I like Jeff great pilots
underpaid loves to drink though but Jeff
will fly from somewhere other than bit
of a lush LaGuardia and and in Baltimore
they have very limited flights every
time I've flown JetBlue it's been a
delight yeah but I can't fly if I don't
have to innovate what I'm saying is
natural selection it cuts out the ones
that can't sustain themselves and the
buyouts just keep them up until if you
if you cut them out
you'd have other ones that build up on
their own and then can sustain right
and that's the issue and this bailout
bill lumps all of these people together
people who would never even consider
want and and pridefully would probably
refuse you know any bailout money
because they've in mind for did that
with the bailouts for decline and the
government made them take the bailout
well I don't know exactly why that is
maybe we can have some research but I
think it had something to do with
equalizing the markets I'm not entirely
sure but Ford didn't want initially they
refused the bailout money because
they're not they're not as crappy as GM
and I know there'll be some people here
who say like Oh GM someone once said I
mean you know what forged ANSF or found
on Road ed you drive a cavalier okay you
drive a metro gee oh yeah it's the
opposite of a chick mobile people leave
your general direction to have sex with
a stranger just so they don't have to
look at you when you're driving in a G
oh yeah well this whole the whole
bailout is based on the idea that the
government knows what to do with your
money better than you do right right and
I know it's a platitude at this point
but it you know it can't the government
cannot make these decisions and cannot
be as targeted as consumers right as
people who actually want the product but
the problem is right now we have
artificially manipulated right to the
market and supplying a man because we
told consumers that they cannot consume
and I don't think that that's very
prudent and I don't know what kind of
ramifications this will have long-term
for for businesses speaking of which
ramifications I think actually we need
to bring in one of our workers here you
know him you love him he climbs a polls
in the office even Brendon
who
we have to have somewhat quarantined
here he's not showing signs he could be
asymptomatic but it's been a problem in
this office we've had our own we are not
unaffected from the coronis care is
running that brendan is it six feet
Brendan yeah that's the federally
Brendan see how far is this okay that's
gotta be at least eight feet yeah okay
that's eight feet hold on a second hold
on a second keep it I set the chair far
enough away so it's set okay - is it far
she was eight
all right so Brendan do tell me you're
Brendan has been usually pretty respond
just had the knee surgery you're feeling
better right yeah good for you you're
making progress of course you were where
are you certain he was supposed to have
surgical gloves no forget it we get it
hold up your hands here in front in
front of the microphone I don't want to
ruin the microphone that's a no-no and
no not in front of I don't want to hold
them closer to me
hold your yeah they're okay almost like
I'll make sure I got this right there
you go
it's Everclear um so what happened
exactly
cuz you were not at any risk of
coronavirus our agreement the reason
we're able to serve you for Mudd Club
for 19 months that's the hashtag is we
all agreed we will only quarantine at
home right and in the office and since
it's broken apart
we never have more than than eight
people in any room at any given time and
then Brendan happened explained the
situation a little bit because we were
all very vexed well so my parents had
scheduled to come down in March months
ahead of time right before all that
happened and the problem was they were
non-refundable tickets well no they were
driving oh yeah okay that's different
well yeah they're gonna drive down and
like because they drove down the March
before so it's like okay I don't leave
it traditions someone could argue it's
almost different from last March yeah
well then I started seeing that like
everything was being locked down I'm
like hey maybe you guys should
reconsider right there's like Panda
yeah there's that seem like we probably
build it too much like we would like go
out did you did you use the word
pandemic no oh well that was your
mistake okay so they were a little
confused okay so they were driving yeah
and then they did move it though right
yeah no I texted I'm like hey maybe you
should reconsider and they're like yeah
now that we see that like your work is
kind of concerned about it and like you
know people are locking down everything
maybe it's a good time to like yeah it's
globo's opponent yeah
and so they postponed it they postponed
it like a couple of weeks or so yeah a
couple weeks they postponed it to closer
to peak ya know then like then like two
days later they said weather looks
pretty good we're gonna come down yeah
see the issue here's weather was not the
delineating factor that wasn't a primary
concern right with your to be fair the
weather was great the weather was
fantastic yeah I get it I understand
what they would want to why they would
want to come down here but I also don't
know that weather is enough of a
justification for stopping at every
motel and Valero gas station all through
the country that's I don't know that's
pretty good weather though was pretty
good weather so then I was kind I was
pretty cavalier remember you said like
hey can they come into the studio yeah
because they're from a pretty rural area
that was my idea they were just coming
down to see me I just thought it'd be
good to like yeah see this well it
wasn't because I didn't think about it
and I was like well they live in a rural
area like you to drive an hour growing
up to find a chick-fil-a right yeah are
you sure that there's only chick-fil-a
one hour from you like have you google
map stat recently no but I mean there's
just whatever we went to a walkie that
was like okay so you go to Milwaukee for
chicken so you would go to Milwaukee
wonderful city by the way a lot going on
really yeah particularly so did you stop
did you like drive to the truck stop
outside of Milwaukee like 194 from
Milwaukee downtown Milwaukee for
chick-fil-a yeah I don't leave it better
get those sweet okay
so then they did travel and I was
cavalier but I remember I said like well
you know me I'm kind of a guilt my
employer my was like okay sure and I
liked it I loved Rena and I wanted to
meet his family yeah and then I went
home and I explained this to my wife and
she said are
you out of your mind that's the change
that I'd say I was like maybe I
shouldn't press for this well what
happens I said fine and my wife said
well the issue is you know um my my
mother who's our wardrobe South she is
she doesn't have Turner virus but she
does have pneumonia right now so that is
something which she hasn't been here hi
mom we've kept her working from home and
she has the costumes delivered as
someone to go pick it up so we don't
want her in the office so that was my
concern and then my wife was the one who
said well it's not real if they come
from a rural area it's that they'd be
stopping at all his different locations
and I believe she said that if they if
they if they deemed it appropriate to
drive up in a pandemic that she wasn't
entirely confident that they had hand
sanitizer that's pretty much what it is
it's the it's it's the calluses and the
cuticles and then then though I spoke
with half-asian bill Richman because I
said well you know what I feel bad
because I gave Brendon the green light
and then Hillary thinks it's a bad idea
and then bill brought up a valid point
oh I didn't know Bill was involved yeah
bill brought up a valid point so I don't
think he said I don't think it matters
you know the way Bill is high up this I
said what do you yeah I asked him I said
I'm concerned it's because I don't want
to go back on my word you know and I'd
like and but I understood the concern
and Bill said well we're his parents
staying
that's a good question yeah in your
one-bedroom apartment no no no no no it
was if they get kicked out of the
campsite that Thursday right were they
know they the campground was open yeah
yeah but they were in your house because
I dropped off beer and an ar-15 oh yeah
he shows up all I had was a picture of a
case of beer and an ar-15 at his house
before and by the way it wasn't even in
panorama view the picture and I could
see the entire apartment it's a cool gun
though but effectively you were in an
incubator well I've always Brendan I
truly believe I'm not just saying this
I'm just starting to see yeah I truly
believe that if we were to do IQ tests
Brendan probably has the highest IQ of
anyone in this office really I really do
think that's the case but
what were you thinking well and uh wait
my parents are usually like really smart
to like right there this is very
uncharacteristic imagine you from good
stock like yeah like they I I'm not
trying to like like throw them under the
bus right no of course not yeah I I
don't know but they have the news
correct yes okay I just wanted to make
sure but well I'm Bruce what what is
your what do you think here is going on
here with Brennan there Bruce Lee
Brendon I have a question for you yes
Bruce how you [ __ ]
that's not nice like he comes from the
place where we're allowing not allowed
to use that language here so what would
you like to say oh you look like you're
about to raise your hand no to say
something oh yeah hold on you know what
raise it anyway you have a question what
would let City your parents in closing
because you were concerned that they
would feel we're not mocking the parents
but I'm kind of sad because I would have
liked to meet your parents right yeah
but I just don't want them you know to
call flood on me right okay contagion
yeah yeah what I want to say to them
yeah what do you wanna say to them
because I gonna see this now and you
know you threw them under the bus I'm
sorry for making it over complicated
yeah adding the extra variable being in
the studio yeah and you know what maybe
we could have them call in and apologize
to you for putting you in that situation
because this is what he has to do now
this is what yes do we can't touch but
we can fist we can fist pound it is ever
clear thank you sanitize put that in a
mask put it on the steam cycle in the
laundry that time measuring tape we love
you Brendan oh my gosh you've already
gone over time let me go really quickly
let's go on to the story number three
we'll take some if you have some chat
let me know because I cannot see the
chat here today by the way this also
works this is another thing the CDC said
don't try and use vodka or any homemade
liquor for sanitizer and they included
Everclear in there Everclear is 190 190
proof okay then I read at the bottom of
that article that says I guess Everclear
could work but if you want to waste the
money just by hand sanitizer no hon a
second
this is cheaper than hand sanitizer I
have to dilute it down to 70% I didn't
ask you to manage my home finances I
wanted to know if ever clear would work
I'm stocked up so I can say this now a
lot of times people ask my favorite
cigar you'll never know because there's
such a low supply of cigars I don't want
you to steal my favorite cigar you'll
know cigars that I like but you won't
know my favorite cigar why because there
are some things that I keep for me I did
I give the discount I'm doing do you
have any idea what it's like to do two
shows a day it's actually pretty fun I
really do appreciate it but I'm just
gonna say well speaking of favorites
annarbor Alex asks what type of roast
are you drinking we're kind of coffee oh
so this actually we just did some coffee
commercials so this I believe is it's
either this the vintage roast that is my
favorite overall roast here's what I
will say about black cup of coffee and
black rifle coffee calm slash Crowder
you get 20% off they're actually doing
up if we can bring this up give and they
sent out an email let me bring this up
right now that's the beauty of it being
why I use the promo code Crowder use the
promo code Crowder you get 20% off but
they're doing a lot of good work here
for veterans let me find this right now
in this okay here you go black rifle
coffee they are donating more than
12,000 bags of coffee along with black
Revell coffee cans coffee and other
coffee related products to first
responders and service members so or
during a 10-day period they'll be
donating a bag I think for everything
you buy I don't know the exact moco this
isn't have to do with us the promo code
is Crowder but I do know that right now
they are donating coffee to service
members and he'd use the promo code
cried or black rifle coffee that come
slash Crowder I will say this we
wouldn't have a sponsor if we didn't
like it and I've talked about this
before black rifle coffee I hated their
coffee at one point really they came by
for a sponsorship and I said no I really
have to explain this
I bought their coffee at a gun store so
I had seen their advertising that said
fresh roasted to deliver yeah and so I
thought okay fresh roasted and I I drank
it and I said that's just that's just
not good coffee it's stale yeah turned
out this was a I spoke with the black
rifle owners no that's not of guns we
actually don't distribute them anymore
because they weren't even following the
rules
and they were keeping leftover old stock
not to shave it okay so let me try the
end plug and this is fantastic this is
my favorite overall roast it's great for
an espresso machine especially of an
automatic I love the gunship roast for
any kind of pour over or drip machine
and then the ak-47 espresso blend is
great as well but I'm not a dark roast
guy whereas dr. Choi my Korean doctor is
story numbers you have another say
someone else says if we all become
zombies that wouldn't be a bad thing
when's the last time you saw a zombie
have to wash their hands or save up some
on some non-perishables well I don't
know if they you know there's no skin on
the hand therefore no skin in the game
there was skin in the game and I don't
know if you need to wash bone how long
does it look like corona lives on steel
for a long period of time it looks on
cardboard for four hours you know yes
those are our superiors they do have an
advantage because they're Undead and
then Story number three I think we
should get to this yes no one else is
covering this we've talked a lot about
coronavirus Joe Biden could be a rapist
so the woman claimed that Biden court
that here's the thing this is this is
important because when the media went
nuts over Donald Trump we'll get the
comparison to Brett Kavanaugh by the way
the media went nuts over Donald Trump
what he was saying was when you're
famous women will let they want anything
from you they'll let you do anything you
can grab him by the pen not a horrible
thing to say but this was he was trying
to create a scenario saying like you can
get away with anything you're saying
you're saying it is a horrible thing to
say yes the horrible thing to say
they'll a but he's saying they let you
which were honestly I'm amazed that he
couched that horrible phrase with
consent he's playing nine dimensional
chess in 2005 they let you I said first
part being operative words they let you
okay and I'd even know how you did it
like a is it a is it a fish hook is it a
couple anyway the point is he was
talking about doing something that was
consensual not sexual assault and I will
say frankly not too far off from what
happens with my wife and I on date night
okay what he were being let you might
grab I'm not saying there but I'm like I
might grab a handful of wherever
what's available it's you grab anything
I like all of it I like grabbing my wife
some might say that's a guy enjoy
relations with my wife so my point here
is um she's watching hi mom in law the
man claims that Biden cornered her and
penetrated her without consent
in 1993 now of course this is IIIi think
that you shouldn't just believe everyone
all the time I think do you think that
due process needs right just like we've
said with Kavanaugh of courtly there was
due process when we found out that it
was all it was
liar [ __ ] Alya [ __ ] and you know it I
believe that was yeah fellas lose on the
record from a jury of the peers even
though there was no jury nor peers it
was just a sound board with Robert De
Niro left has not been playing by their
rules well so let's compare right now
this stuff happening with Biden and I
again I don't know whether it's credible
or not but considering that he's running
for president and how we had again that
grabbed him by the vagina playing like a
loop like a [ __ ] drip just like right
now the hundred thousand deaths they
should at least give some airtime as
someone who I was raped right you think
I didn't ask him to grab me by the P
word in a hypothetical scenario to which
he obliged which really would be the
Donald Trump scenario it's this man he
raped me and no coverage let's compare
that to Brett Kavanaugh were by the way
we know that none of these things could
be corroborated right we know that half
of the people who came forward stories
particularly the gang rape stories
recanted I'm saying I just wanted to get
on TV and Christine Blasi Ford then
raised several million dollars on a
GoFundMe and she was presenting
different stories as a psychologist and
to the authorities that didn't match up
with people who weren't there who were
not witnesses from places that don't
even exist so let's be clear about Blasi
Ford here we go
the media Washington Post they mentioned
Ford Christine Blasi Ford dr. Christie
yes 100 times Wow write and read mrs.
Reid is the one who's accused Joe Biden
zero yeah New York Times Ford 90 times
anyone want to guess the references to
read the woman who alleges that Joe
Biden r870 right by the way I should say
actually have this here it's one it's
100 plus
Oh 100-plus at night it's like it's like
20,000 deaths or much less I'm getting a
little loose because I think I don't
have that much time with the morning
show you look up every single rep I know
it's at least 100 MSNBC reference
Christine Blasi Ford 100-plus times
read zero so we've just gone through now
keep in mind Washington Post is used as
one of the reputable fact checkers yeah
for YouTube and Twitter yeah right they
were the ones who were using what is
Washington Post the truth-o-meter the
Pinocchio's I don't I think Washington
Post is Pinocchio's Snopes is a true
Snyder Snopes was the pinoke there's
truth reader Pinocchio's liar liar pants
on fire they all try to get cute
there's the gene Shalit of fact checkers
so Washington Post gets to dictate this
is another thing people to people who
understand the algorithm on YouTube and
Twitter by the way the algorithms that
determine I think was Laura engrams
tweet regarding the Chinese coronavirus
the masks not working removed there were
videos that were suppressed tutting
chloroquine right on YouTube and on
Twitter because they were saying it's
fake news right no those people get that
back by the way now that it's been
approved by the FDA
now that they've actually had to recall
these masks so keep in mind these
algorithms that remove those tweets that
suppress those videos that when you put
up a video talking about as we did we
did this you can go back and watch we
talked about the combination of
chloroquine last week at Melinda's last
week and a link on that video was did
you want to be redirected to this wasn't
even Wikipedia with some kind of coded
reference page yes and we could see that
this video was not showing up as brows
or suggested well guess what that could
have helped a lot of people sure but the
point is that algorithm that directed
people away from us talking about
chloroquine which is now if they approve
determining it to be fake news all of
these algorithms are created by someone
at some point right who is determined
that us talking about clerkly which
again cannot stress enough FDA approved
now for emergency treatment who is
determining that algorithm to redirect
away from our content
Washington Post the Southern Poverty Law
Center Snopes this is the place that has
a hundred plus references to Ford and
zero to read and they're the ones in
all of the equations I don't know I
assume it's like goodwill goodwill
hunting where there's equations on the
walls and [ __ ] inputting the algorithm
that will exist forever more that never
seems to be recalibrated and corrected
in the right way that's why this is
concerning not saying that we should go
out and give read the ford treatment
because conservatives are consistent i
think there needs to be some kind of
proof i think that when you compare the
track record this is speculation of
christine Blasi ford or you compare the
track record of Brett Kavanaugh where
they couldn't find anything to Vice
President Joe Biden who routinely sniffs
small tweens on camera the American
public is more likely to believe the
latter and that's the thing they had to
do so much late work for Brett Kavanaugh
and Ford turned up nothing right it just
goes to show it's all about power
weights it's yeah it's not about who it
is it's not about the actual principles
that they've shown that they're not
principled this shown that it doesn't
matter they can't follow their own rule
by the way really yes good really
quickly and I want to come back to this
really quick let's bring this up CNN
look still path hospitals health care
workers overwhelmed we've been happy
we've had this on all morning there has
been no mention of the masks the
sanitizing masks no mention of the
approved new therapeutics no mention of
the progress or headway that we're
making why do you need an hour and a
half to talk about how some hospitals
are overburdened yeah no time you can't
give a chi run to we stepped up testing
faster than in the history of ever
just one yeah but Steven that would be
helpful keep listening this is CNN this
is in context we've all learned history
right in school you are schooled but
we've all read history books what do you
think would rightfully go in the history
books if you read a chapter that some
hospitals were overburdened that might
get a paragraph that we're graph and a
half a minute kids learning history will
probably learn that the private sector
stepped up retooled and created more
supplies than ever in the history of the
American workforce and created new
medical innovations that had never
before been seen across the globe that's
what the history book will read so right
now in a monument this moment in history
I think all of us would agree CNN isn't
even tracking with what will be in the
syllabus for fifth graders okay and
going back to this this is my point
Christine Blasi Ford they had to go up
there and make up stories right with
Ford they had to make up a gang rape
they ran a train on her
remember they provided this opinion this
commentary we believe that you know
we'll do we'll do a broad again we'll
have him on on Friday apologize because
he's probably already too drunk they
were um with with a lousy Ford remember
they had Donald Trump is nocturnal Trump
sorry Brit Cavanaugh cocked his head
back and laughed rather an article he he
gang-raped and cocked his head back and
laughed that's what they did that's what
they had to try and run with to convince
the American public and by the way it
didn't really work now the reason it
didn't work was because by it by all
evidence that we have available to us
was untrue now they haven't covered read
the accusations against Joe Biden at all
so a hundred plus references to zero why
do you think that is they wouldn't have
to make anything up with Joe Biden they
wouldn't have that uphill battle they
before they finish before they finish
the headline like if they're about to
announce it before going to the break
and they are going to say hey after the
break we will talk with mrs. Reid the
accuser who says that Joe Biden raped
people are going to vote guilty you mean
the guy the Mike a guy who rubs
shoulders has designed girls giving him
lap dances at pizza parlors it's in
front of the camera and sniffs small
children guilty you're not to say Joe
Biden went to a party and jammed a Red
Solo Cup up somebody's rectum to get
people to believe it you just say Joe
Biden was being Joe Biden and this lady
claims she was raped and everyone would
believe it you would see more of a
disapproval rating against Joe Biden
immediately then you saw at any point
against Cavanaugh during that trial why
because it's more believable I'm not
saying that it's true but it is
remarkable how much work and effort they
put into ruining the reputation of
Cavanaugh who kept a journal for crying
out loud
he kept a journal that vindicated
because he was such a dork
yeah his biggest crime was he likes a
few Schlitz on weekdays sometimes come
on Shobha smells children I'm sure Bruce
Lee has some thoughts about this as well
what do you thoughts on the Joe Biden
issue there with the children well you
see when Joe Biden smells children he
can crash he can sniff or he can snarl
if you put Joe Biden into a playpen
he becomes the play if you put Joe Biden
into a nursery
he becomes a nursery and he is guilty
oh by previos yeah that's true did you
appreciate it rightful I told you that
time he gave us a definitive conclusion
right yeah
any new areas good we have to what
commercials do we have do we have time
for a commercial I don't think we have
time for a commercial break that's right
was it a black rifle come yeah yeah we
talked about is there anyone else I need
to mention I think we're good I think
we're good all right well Walter of
course you guys know guns and gun sales
are surging please do our own sales
pitch for Walter just try the Walter
there are a lot of great firearms out
that we've talked about Sig HK Glock
certain points like Mercedes or BMW and
I know right now looking at people do a
4-1 Road ed just that's not the point
the point is at a certain point they're
all good quality firearms so I'm not
going to do the whole you've been using
Brand X that being said run a Google
search Walther PPQ review Walter PPS
review you will not find anything less
than a stellar review it is the
best-kept secret in the firearm industry
and they have the balls to sponsor the
show so do consider Walter and of course
black rifle coffee it's better than most
coffee they fresh roasted black rifle
coffee at commis flash Crowder enter the
promo code 20% off do we have some more
chats yeah let's go to some chats and
then we'll wrap this up for today
perfect all right so let's see what are
y'all's advice when it comes to being a
conservative libertarian millennial who
is in Asheville North Carolina known as
the San Francisco of the East Coast so
my name is Michael and I'm a mug clubber
suicide hey Michael so I'm on YouTube
don't take that but it is always an
option so I would say no it's never an
option it's not for an option we speak
for billing you say never ever never
ever ever except for one it is so what I
do think is important to note is um
at one point this is something I've
changed on people said what have you
changed your mind on you know because
you're so rigid I've changed my mind on
pot that's something I change my mind
I've talked about this and not in the
sense that I I put the video yeah right
now no sense that I want to foot the
bill for for stoners who are
unproductive but I do think that right
now we need to remove it from the is it
Schedule one substance list because of
the CVD issues and there does seem to be
some medical promise for CBD and I
always thought the station other right
to legalize it but I didn't like the
idea of it if it were in my state I
would vote to legalize it now but
regulated in other words people
shouldn't be just anyway that's
something I've changed my mind on and
then something else that I've change my
mind on I used to tell people hey listen
keep your head down until you are in a
position where you can be open about
your views because I don't want anyone
losing work particularly the
entertainment industry I've changed my
opinion on that because you don't have
that luxury now I used to give this
advice maybe going back to 2009 maybe
through 2012 we didn't have the kind of
landscape that we have today where there
is nowhere to hide if you have ever made
a Facebook post if you have ever put out
a tweet if you have ever released a
video or if you've ever been at a party
or gathering or function ten people or
less where politics have come up and
you've expressed a center-right opinion
that'll you'll never be able get away
from it and I see people now trying to
distance themselves from people who I
know who who I know and my personal life
agree with me and we spent time together
then go on Twitter trying to say oh I've
changed my that they haven't and I go I
understand why you're doing this but
these people are not going to like you
they're never going to be your friends
so this is where the change my mind
comes in right the idea is find the
people whose minds you can change and
then the people whose minds you cannot
change make an example of them for the
people who are watching I would say do
the right thing right if you're a
libertarian millennial in Asheville I
think he said by the way sorry about
that Grand Rapids stole your title beer
City USA I think four years and running
so that's there's another reason that
you know you should move to Grand Rapids
that's a I mean not take anything
drastic measures but you know Grand
Rapids or so don't here's what I would
say do the right thing but don't be
afraid to be the bad guy
do the right thing but don't live your
whole life afraid of people calling you
a bad guy because guess what we've been
called a bad Joe Rogan was called a bad
guy because he said that a guy who lived
his entire life as a man and the within
the next six months and without
disclosing it to an athletic commission
caved in a woman's orbital might be a
bridge too far as it relates to
transgender athletes in sports and he
was the bad guy don't be afraid of being
the bad guy if you're doing the right
thing and I do think that that's most
important to keep sight of when we're
looking at this right now because I mean
it's everyone's going to be offended and
this is remarkable too I think Artie
Lange was talking about this with
Anthony Kamiya you know back then I used
to be on radio back in the day the FCC
was sort of the man you would stick it
to now podcasts are free right they're
open and available there's no censor but
they're more censored than ever well
because it's not the FCC who might give
you a fine for saying something
scatological it's you are basically
outcast from society for saying the
wrong thing yeah and that can come from
what once upon a time was just someone
listening from the radio who didn't like
it and turn it off they go onto social
media and get it amplified and what
happens you're no longer advert you're
no longer brand friendly on YouTube and
so people who might have been edgy at
some point maybe skirt of the lines with
the FT FCC and had to pay a fine but was
a part of the show they couldn't do this
they can make zero living today yeah
because they're not brand friendly so we
are more censored than ever even though
we were anticipating not having any
gatekeepers and being able to
communicate with people directly and
that's why mug club is so important and
the sponsors that we have because we're
not monetized here on the main steven
crowder channel at all that has yet to
be remedied and we're sponsored by
viewers like you not a foreign caliphate
and that's why of course we're trying to
serve you as best we can that's why
we're taking your live chat people who
are already mug club members entering
the promo code Crowder you get $30 off
throughout the entire month of April at
a lot of credit come /mo Club LA doors
credit calm /schedule so you can see
when we air episodes we'll be doing some
live streams as well like this is
obviously a live stream Jean G will be
live streaming video game yes I believe
with Dena glow and we'll just be doing
some live chat shows with you in the
evening
so go check out that schedule so you can
see when you can interact with us live
but it is remarkable that we are at a
point right now where we
our less free than ever to say the
things that as entertainers and as
reporters and comedians and you know
take the whole spectrum it should be our
duty to say it really our duty is to
entertain you primarily unfortunately we
also take on the duties of the media
because right now they're still look
they're still at CNN we don't even bring
it up but we don't even hear it they're
still just talking about cases and
deaths they're not talking about any of
the population they're any of them so we
feel that it's our duty to express that
though we'd rather you know have Bruce
Lee in third chair or Vernon in a dog
cone we find that more enjoyable but it
is it is a scary time and so we really
do appreciate you guys signing up in
supporting us we really do appreciate
everyone who sent the well wishes and I
know you're concerned about me over
working I've gotten some of those
messages we are trying to make sure that
we keep this a feasible burden for
everyone on the team and we are willing
to take the acceptable risk right now
coming in and serving you because I know
how lonely it is out there and this
isn't of your doing we know that a lot
of you would love to be able to go
outside but you don't want to be shot in
the street like you know you're a
pedophile circa 1840 - I think that's
what it was pedophile so I don't know
the point is I understand it I don't
think they were completely out of line
because I had city line we don't hate
you you just can't be around kids so I
know that many of you are stuck home
quarantined against your will this is
the only way we could think to give back
was to create more content than ever
before and give you as steep of a
discount as we can possibly afford while
still keeping people here employed
because we know there are record layoffs
we really appreciate the support we do
consider it a privilege to be here with
you every morning Monday Wednesday
Friday and then every night Monday
through Thursday thank you so much do
hit the notification bell subscribe to
Crowder bits and of course the that's
not iTunes anymore Apple podcasts we
will see you what is tonight tonight is
oh we have an ash Wednesday tonight and
some crank calls coming your way see you
then
[Music]